benvenuta vittoria secchezza una sana
come mai se vi interessano i fili
interdentali tipo questo c'è una super
promozione 3 al 79 euro 90 guarda è
comodissimo
allora questo ce l'abbiamo li ho portato
che parlate un accurato zebrato età allo
volevi rosa e no rosa non c'è tu sei
nata principessa ma se crescita
guerriera prendi questo lo chiamiamo 50
su moto e di pizzano in negozio il tour
impazziranno lei un lui ma diane che mi
sconvolge comprarlo per la tua lei ma
non è neanche una lei va beh sai che c'è
troppo e comprare anche per te stessa
c'è chi guardi allo specchio ici cavolo
speso 190 euro ma sono una [ __ ] atomica
e
vediamo cosa hai scelto ma insomma se è
bastata una 50 fumatori di pizzo cima da
sfumature di ciclo sarà come da tonino
no dicevo bancomat sono 34 euro e 90
appoggia cura
grazie alla prossima